dede l'invasion russe. Que fautl
pepenser d de la stratégie
dede Vladimir Poutine en Ukrain?
LeLe renseignement est un élémet
imimportant de toute opération
mimilitaire.
J J'en ai parlé un peu plus tôt
avavec Sergueï Jirnov, un ancien
esespion du KGB qui a brièvement
coconnu Vladimir Poutine.
IlIl vit en France depuis 2001
enen tant que réfugié politique
etet vient de faire paraître
"L"L'Éclaireur", sa biographie.
M Monsieur Jirnov, bonsoir.
BiBienvenue à 24/60.
- - Bonsoir.
- - Alors, comme ancien espion
dudu KGB, vous avez connu Vladir
PoPoutine. Au sixième jour
dede cette guerre qui prend fin,
mamais le septième, ou la septie
nunuit va venir bientôt, on crat
évévidemment le pire, notamment
àà Kiev. Et croyez-vous que
VlVladimir Poutine est frustré,
huhumilié des scénarios auxquels
onon assiste en ce moment
pupuisqu'il n'a toujours pas
rerencontré ses objectifs?
- - Oui, je crois. Je crois
paparce que c'est une personne
ququi est... c'est une personne
asassez particulièrement...
asassez particulière au niveau
pspsychologique. Donc, bien
évévidemment, je crois comme tot
lele monde qu'il a sous-estimé
lala possibilité de résistance
dedes Ukrainiens. Il a surestimé
lala possibilité de conquérir
l'l'Ukraine. Donc, il est
plplutôt frustré.
- - Oui. Et quel est le rôle
dudu renseignement, soit
lele renseignement russe, ou mêe
dudu renseignement ukrainien, ou
mmême des alliés, sur le terrain
dadans cette guerre fratricide?
- - Bien, dans toutes les guerr,
lele renseignement joue un rôle
trtrès important parce que
çaça permet de bien planifier ls
frfrappes pour celui qui frappe,
etet de bien planifier la défene
popour celui qui se défend.
EnEn revanche, il y a autre choe
ququi se passe avec Poutine. Son
rerenseignement, j'ai l'impressn
ququ'il ne lui donne pas le vrai
rerenseignement, mais il lui doe
cece qu'il veut entendre.
PaParce que...
J Je ne sais pas, vous,
auau Canada, vous n'avez pas vu
cecette scène, le 21 février,
ququand il y avait le conseil
dede guerre de Poutine, où il la
huhumilié Narychkine, le chef
dudu SVR. Et on a compris qu'en
fafait, il avait une relation
trtrès particulière avec
lele renseignement. Déjà, le
rerenseignement politique, vous
avavez compris. Il le méprisait,
dodonc il a humilié publiquemen.
DoDonc, ça vous démontre aussi
quque la relation avec Poutine,
avavec les gens qui travaillent
dadans le renseignement
n'n'est pas si simple que ça.
- - Et même avec ses généraux,
onon a vu des regards, des yeux
sese fermer, des paupières
sese fermer devant l'ordre
dede Poutine. Donc, croyez-vous
ququ'il puisse y avoir aututour
dede lui, que ce soit au niveau
dudu KGB, au niveau des générau,
unune certaine dissidence qui
s's'installe parce qu'on juge
cecette guerre injustifiée?
- - Bien, de toute façon,
cecette guerre est injustifiée.
EtEt il y a beaucoup de gens
auautour de lui, à mon avis, qui
lele croyaient, mais qui n'osait
papas le dire, surtout dans
lele renseignement, qui savaient
auaussi que cette guerre
nene peut pas être gagnée.
D D'ailleurs, par rapport à ça,
ilil faut citer le général Leond
IvIvachov, c'est l'ancien chef
dede la direction générale
dede la coopération internatione
mimilitaire au ministère de la
DéDéfense, qui, le 31 janvier,
trtrois semaines avant l'attaqu,
a a publié une lettre ouverte
àà Vladimir Poutine au nom
dede l'association panrusse
dedes officiers. Et dans cette
dédéclaration, il a d'abord dit
quque cette guerre n'a pas,
nene doit pas être menée, que
leles militaires ne veulent pasa
memener, que la Russie n'a pas s
momoyens de la mener, que Poutie
dodoit démissionner de son poste
dede commandant en chef, que tos
leles officiers doivent... ne
dodoivent pas exécuter les ordrs
ququi sont les ordres criminels,
etet que si jamais Poutine
cocommençait cette guerre,
d'd'abord, il ne pourra jamais
lala gagner, et ensuite,
cecette guerre sera la perte
dede la fédération de Russie.
C'C'est pour vous montrer...
- - Mais pourquoi il ne peut pas
lala gagner, cette guerre?
LaLa supériorité de la Russie
esest tellement plus grande que
cecelle de l'Ukraine. Et l'OTAN
n'n'intervient pas, sauf
enen fournissant des armes.
- - Il ne peut pas la gagner pae
quque la supériorité militaire
nene régit pas tout. Je peux vos
rarappeler que la supériorité
dedes Américains qui combattaiet
auau Vietnam était peut-être
10100 fois supérieure à la force
mimilitaire des Vietnamiens.
PoPourtant, c'est les Vietnamies
ququi ont gagné la guerre.
LaLa supériorité soviétique
enen Afghanistan était 1000 fois
susupérieure aux Afghans.
PoPourtant, c'est les soviétiqus
ququi ont perdu cette guerre.
L La supériorité russe était
pepeut-être 10 ou 100 fois plus
quque la supériorité des
TcTchétchènes; pourtant, c'est s
TcTchétchènes qui ont gagné cete
guguerre. Parce que contrairemet
àà ce qu'il raconte, Poutine,
lala Russie a perdu la guerre
enen Tchétchénie. En Tchétchéni,
nonous avons actuellement
unun khalifa islamiste, dirigé
papar Ramzan Kadyrov, qui est
unun djihadiste islamique.
EtEt les lois russses ne
fofonctionnent pas en Russie.
EtEt la Russie paye à la
TcTchétchénie une redevance
enentre 1 milliard et 5 milliars
dede dollars par an.
- - En même temps, on a mobilis,
sesemble-t-il, 400 Tchétchènes
etet plus pour venir supporter
l'l'invasion de l'Ukraine.
- - Bien, justement, justement,
c'c'est ça. En fait, c'est
lele contrat que Poutine a passé
avavec Kadyrov. Donc, en fait, l
a a reconnu de fait l'indépendae
dede la Tchétchénie. Kadyrov
fafait dans la Tchétchénie
cece qu'il veut. En revanche,
ququand Poutine a besoin
popour faire une sale besogne,
ilil fait appel à Kadyrov.
- - Poutine dit une chose, selon
cecertains observateurs, et fait
lele contraire. Il y a un convoi
ququi serait à l'arrêt aux ports
dede Kiev. Les choses pourraient
chchanger. Mais il y a quand mêe
dedes bombardements importants
auaujourd'hui. La station
dede télévision qui a coupé
lala diffusion des émissions.
EtEt juste à côté, ce mémorial e
l'l'Holocauste, c'est un paradoe
asassez incroyable. Mais donc,
cecette nuit pourrait être
teterrible. Alors, Poutine fait
çaça, mais en même temps, on est
àà la veille des négociations.
PoPoutine est-il fiable?
EsEst-ce que ça vaut la a peine
dede s'asseoir avec sa délégati?
- - Poutine n'a jamais été fiabe
dadans les négociations. Poutine
esest un manipulateur, est
unun menteur patenté. D'ailleur,
enen Russie, nous avons un petit
didicton populaire qui dit :
"S"Si vous voyez à la télévision
PoPoutine bouger les lèvres, c't
ququ'il est en train de mentir."
DoDonc, en fait, nous, les Russ,
onon n'a pas énormément
dede croyance et de... on ne crt
papas Poutine sincère.
E En revanche, vous savez ce qi
sese passe avec les négociation.
LeLes négociations avec Poutine
acactuellement, elles sont plus
imimportantes pour l'Occident,
popour le monde entier, parce
quque... Je pourrais les comparr
auaux pourparlers que mène un
pspsychiatre avec un malade menl
ququi est en train de faire une
crcrise, une crise de démence.
C'C'est aussi, on peut la compar
àà des pourparlers que mènent
leles gens de Spetsnaz lorsqu'il
y y a un forcené qui a pris
dedes otages. Dt donc, bien
évévidemment, il faut mener
avavec ce forcené et les otages
avavant d'enclencher l'assaut.
E Et donc, ces pourparlers,
a a permet aussi... Vous savez e
ququi se passe au Kremlin. Poute
a a construit un système dans
lelequel il n'y a plus personne
ququi lui dit la vérité. Il est
cocomplètement coupé de la vérié
etet il est dans sa bulle.
EtEt les seules personnes qui
pepeuvent encore lui raconter
cece qui se passe réellement,
cece sont les dirigeants
ététrangers. Donc, il faut
gagarder cette ligne rouge pour
lului rappeler tout simplement
lala réalité de l'autre côté.
- - Le renseignement américain,
c'c'est le Pentagone qui annonçt
auaujourd'hui qu'il y a des unis
rurusses qui font défection et i
sasabotent même leur équipement
mimilitaire. Qu'est-ce que
çaça annonce, selon vous?
- - Bien, c'est une bonne annon.
D'D'ailleurs, on a eu cela même
avavant l'attaque parce que
leles premières informations
dede défection, et nous sommes
paparvenus, deux jours avant
lele commencement de l'attaque,
c'c'est-à-dire tout de suite aps
lala proclamation du 21 février,
mamais avant le 24, le début des
opopérations. Parce que dans ces
ununités, il y a des appelés, ms
ilil y a aussi des contractuels.
E Et donc, les gens qui étaient
leles contractuels, lorsqu'ils t
cocompris qu'ils allaient être
enenvoyés dans un pays où il n'a
auaucune motive... aucune
momotivation pour faire une
guguerre, donc ils ont compris
ququ'il était peut être temps
d'd'abandonner cette guerre
paparce qu'ils risquaient
dede se retrouver après
cocomme des criminels de guerre.
P Parce qu'il faut bien rappelr
quque cette guerre, c'est une
guguerre criminelle. L'Ukraine
n'n'a jamais rien fait contre
lala Russie. L'histoire de l'OT,
c'c'est une histoire complètemet
ininventée par Poutine parce que
l'l'OTAN non plus n'a jamais
cocombattu contre la Russie.
L'L'OTAN possède déjà les bases
enen Turquie. Depuis les quais,
dedepuis ces bases, il peut
atatteindre toutes les cibles
quque Poutine a dénommées quand
ilil disait que le rapprochement
dede l'OTAN va causer une énorme
avavancée à l'OTAN. Donc, si vos
prprenez, par exemple, l'Estonie
etet la Turquie, l'OTAN peut
atatteindre tout ce qu'il peut,
totout ce qu'il veut, avant
leles monts Oural en Russie.
DoDonc, tout ça, c'est bidon.
E Et donc, voilà, oublier tout
çaça. Et d'ailleurs, cette guer,
PoPoutine la met uniquement
popour punir le peuple ukrainie,
ququi est un peuple libre, qui t
unun peuple démocratique. C'est
unun peuple et qui a voulu choir
lele modèle européen et le modèe
cicivilisé de développement.
EtEt ça a renvoyé à Poutine une
imimage qui lui était dégradant,
paparce que c'est une image
ququasiment accusatrice. Parce e
lului, il est là depuis 22 ans t
ilil pense rester encore 14 ans.
EtEt donc, bien évidemment,
ilil ne pouvait pas supporter ç.
E Et puis, l'Ukraine a rejeté
àà deux reprises le protégé
dede Poutine, Ianoukovitch. La
prpremière fois, quand Poutine a
prprésenté, l'Ukraine ne l'a pas
élélu. La deuxième fois, ils l't
élélu, mais ils l'ont renversé n
202014. Et donc, du coup, Pouti,
qui est quelqu'un ququi est
trtrès rancunier, quelqu'un
ququi est très peu sûr de lui,
dodonc il punit leles Ukrainiens
ununiquement pour ça.
L La Russie n'a pas besoin
dede territoire. La Russie posse
1717,5 millions de kilomètres
cacarrés. Ce territoire russe, x
dedeux tiers, n'est pas dévelop.
OnOn n'a pas de routes. On a
enencore des bâtiments stalinie.
OnOn a encore des bâtiments même
d'd'avant la révolution d'Octob.
LaLa Russie possède toutes
leles richesses qu'il lui faut.
LLà non plus, il n'a pas besoin
d'augmenter les richesses,
susurtout que l'Ukraine est plus
papauvre par rapport à la Russi.
DoDonc, pour Poutine, il n'y a
auaucune motivation pragmatique
dede mener cette guerre. La seue
prpreuve... la seule motivation
dede Poutine, c'est une vengeane
pepersonnelle.
- - Là-dessus, Sergueï Jirnov,
memerci beaucoup de nous avoir
paparlé ce soir depuis la Franc.
EtEt j'espère qu'on pourra
sese reparler et que les choses
évévolueront dans un bon sens
popour l'histoire et la paix.
MeMerci à vous.
- - De toute façon... Oui, merc.
DeDe toute façon, Poutine ne pet
papas la gagner, cette guerre.
- - Oui, vous le disiez tout
àà l'heure. Bon, espérons
quque vous avez raison. Merci
bebeaucoup. On se reparle. Merci
vrvraiment d'avoir accepté notre
ininvitation. C'est très générex
dede votre part. Merci.
- - Merc